un camion de pompier c'est un jouet pour
les garçons une poupée barbie c'est un
jouet pour les filles un livre de super
héros c'est pour les garçons un livre de
princesse c'est pour les filles
qu'on le veuille ou non et encore pas
mal les stéréotypes de genre qui sont
associées au monde de l'enfance mais
l'on sera dans une garderie de montréal
qui a décidé de s'y attaquer en
intervenant auprès des enfants mais
aussi des parents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le thème de la fête cp les tests mais
olivier elle voulait pas être une
princesse une série d'ateliers
le thème étant la différence donc ce
qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a une
éducatrice de 4 5 ans qui étaient très
intéressés par ce sujet d'après les
leurs pour un peu corrigé le tir quand
il entend des commentaires aussi à
l'antenne enfants qui dit oh non tu
dessines en cause d un petit gars t'as
pas le droit tout de suite et morilles
orienter la conversation pendant une
forme met l'accent sur le fait que tout
le monde peut faire ce qu'ils veulent
que la différence va nous on la respecte
et on l'installé redresser quand je
faisais on est toutes palais mais on est
différente
on a eu des enfants qui se faisait dire
nous voyons tu peux pas jouer avec les
poupées y était un petit gars et on
voyait le temps que ça la cause est
qu'on avait des parents qui vivaient
sans et qu'ils ne commencent que je peux
aider mon enfant et on avait des parents
qui était très en colère car leurs
enfants jeudi vous en princesse
c'est surtout dans les petits gars aller
vers les jeux qu'on peut tirer le pays
vers de petites fait qu'on s'est dit
comment est ce qu'on peut arrêter sont
brisées sont très très très rapidement
il ya aussi la documentation qui est à
faire aux parents sur la question des
jouets dangereux
oui pourquoi parce que c'est pas si j'ai
connu à qu'on ait pris ce qu'on
connaissait et on ne peut marcher on a
retravaillé dans l'em2 pourquoi c'est
important pour votre enfant
parce que dans le fond si tu offres un
enfant juste une petite fille juste des
petites baies roses
il ya plein de choses qu'elle va pas
développer si tu fais un petit garçon
juste des camions de construction des
dinosaures rares ya plein de choses
qu'elle livre pour développer vous comme
parent vous en pensez quoi de cette
initiative
moi j'adore je trouve que c'est vraiment
une grande ouverture d'esprit pour les
enfants et une grande nature sur l'autre
sur leur route ils ont grand libertis a
eu à choisir n'y a pas de barrière n'y a
pas de frontière et ils font ce qu'ils
veulent c'est des enfants c'est même pas
une lutte réfléchit c'est qu' on essaie
les valeurs qu'on a
et puis c'est l'inclusion de tout le
monde sentiments
[Musique]